Bitte schön.
Guten Abend.
Ich heiße Mohammed Hamidin.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistentarzt tätig
und wurde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ne Kleine.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen
und dann kommen wir zu Ihren allgemeinen aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist es in Ordnung?
Ja, ne Kleine.
Begen Sie los.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Peter Müller.
Peter Müller?
Peter Müller.
Herr Müller,
können Sie bitte vor dem Namen wuchsch tabieren?
Also, P wie Paula, E wie Emil, T wie Theodor,
E wie Emil und R wie Richard. Peter.
Peter, ha, okay, Peter.
Peter Müller.
Ja, okay, Herr Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre alt.
Entschuldigung, weil das stimmt nicht sehr klar.
Erkustikprobleme.
Okay, und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1974.
1978.
Ja, okay, 474.
Ja.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 1 Meter 87 groß.
Und wie viel 95 Kilo?
Wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
Noch einmal bitte.
95 Kilo.
95 Kilogramm, okay.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Was Sie zu uns, die gerne ich Ihnen helfen.
Also, ich habe seit ungefähr 2-3 Wochen
wieder mal ganz starken Oberbauchschmerzen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen, bitte?
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Also, die Schmerzen stehen in der Mitte.
Also, so mehr Mitte.
Und manchmal hat man ein bisschen Eindruck, die Schmerzen sind auch...
Akustik, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben wieder Oberbauchschmerzen im Mitte.
Also, in der Mitte, ja richtig, Oberbauchschmerzen, mehr Mitte.
Und manchmal strahlt der Schmerz auch in die rechte Schulter aus.
Rüster Schulter.
Und sind die Schmerzen langsam
oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Also, die kommen so allmählich.
Dann sind sie extrem stark.
Und nach einer gewissen Zeit gehen die dann wieder weg.
Allmählich.
Ja.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, ob ein Loser gibt?
Zum Beispiel nach Fettessen oder nach Bewegung.
Sie meinen Auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Ja, Auslöser.
Ja.
Also, ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, dass es mit dem Essen zusammenhängt.
Das fängt so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde bis eine Stunde später nach dem Essen an.
Und ist dann so nach zwei, drei Stunden am stärksten und dann wird es wieder weniger?
Dann weniger.
Nach Essen etwa eine halbe Stunde und sich verstellt bis drei Stunden.
Und dann wieder weniger werden.
Ja, richtig.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden in diesem Bereich?
Zum Beispiel Druckgefühl, Vollgefühl.
Also, ob oder selbst?
Nee, gar nicht.
Das sind einfach diese extrem starken Schmerzen.
Die kann ich, die halte ich nicht mehr aus.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, okay.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Ist Ihnen oben und haben Sie erbrochen?
Herr Breschen.
Nee, nee, erbrochen habe ich nicht und Übelkeit habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Fieber habe, aber ich hatte den Eindruck,
so in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen nach dem Berat ist,
dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen Temperatur gehabt habe.
Aber ich habe nicht gemessen, vielleicht war es auch Fieber.
Ja, ich verstehe, Sie denken, Sie haben Fieber, aber nicht gemessen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Fieber war, aber ich hatte erhöhte Temperatur.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Und der Schütterlnwurst?
Ja, vorgestern hatte ich den Eindruck, mir ist es so ein bisschen kalt.
Das war nicht normal, das kannte ich jetzt so nicht.
Und auch da war die Temperatur auch ein bisschen hoch gewesen.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, Herr Müller, haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nee, damit habe ich kein Problem.
Okay.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden irgendwann?
Sie meinen, ob ich früher mal solche Beschwerden gehabt habe?
Ja, früher.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Schon einmal?
Nee, bisher.
Nee, so etwas hatte ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, das ist der erste Mann.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich frage jetzt, ob ich vor Erkrankungen habe.
Haben Sie chronische oder vor Erkrankungen?
Ich meine z.B. Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder Schildrosehäberfunktion.
Nee, also mir ist da nichts bekannt.
Wurden Sie schon einmal berührt?
Nein, Operationen habe ich keine gehabt bisher.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen etwas?
Allergien sind mir jetzt auch nicht bekannt.
Ja, das ist gut, ich freue mich.
Und der Unverzweglichkeit?
Also, generell oder gegen Medikamente?
Generell, Medikamente.
Also, ich vertrage so Kaffee nicht, aber sonst geht es mir gut.
Kaffee?
Ja.
Kaffee und Verzweglichkeit?
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen Kindererkrankungen geimpft?
Ja.
Oder unter Corona geimpft?
Gegen Corona, ja.
Gegen Kindererkrankungen, ja, in der Kindheit.
Ich habe sie jetzt nicht mehr kontrolliert.
Aber meine Eltern haben mich mit Sicherheit impfen lassen.
Sie haben geimpft, das verstehe ich.
Ja, ja.
Und gegen Corona auch?
Ja, gegen Corona bin ich jetzt mittlerweile viermal geimpft.
Ja, viermal, super, sehr gut.
Sehr selten mit viermal.
Normalerweise zwei, drei Mal, sehr gut.
Ja, vor drei Wochen habe ich mich dann gegen die Omikron-Variante
auch nochmal impfen lassen.
Ja, super.
Das ist sehr fremig.
Haben Sie schon in der letzten Zeit lange Reise im Ausland?
Ja, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Ich habe gefragt, ob ich lange Reise in der letzten Zeit lange Reise hatte.
Hören Sie mich?
Ja, ich habe gefragt, ob ich lange Reise hatte.
Nein, nein, seit der Pandemie, seit zwei Jahren war ich nicht im Ausland.
Ja, okay.
Herr Müller, bevor wir weitere anemnestische Fragen stellen,
ich möchte noch eine Frage über die aktuelle Beschwerden.
Wie ist die Schmerzintensität auf der Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starke Entspüchten.
Also, wenn die Schmerzen am stärksten sind, würde ich bei 6, 7 sagen.
6, 7.
Herr Müller, haben Sie Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Nein, ich habe jetzt nur in den letzten Tagen immer wieder mal Ibuprofen
genommen wegen der starken Schmerzen.
Aber sonst bin ich kein Fan von Medikamenten.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Welche Dosierung?
400 Milligramm Tabletten, die man in der Apotheke bekommt.
100 Milligramm, okay.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Müller?
Nein, ich haue mich.
Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol ganz selten.
Wenn ich mal eingeladen bin zu Geburtstagsfeiern
oder irgendwelche Firmen feiern, dann vielleicht mal, aber sonst nicht.
Nur bei Feiertagen?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Herr Müller, Sie bitte, diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Es ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nee, damit habe ich nichts am Boot.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich stelle ein paar Fragen über Familien,
die in einem Nest leben.
Ja, ja, die sind noch am Leben.
Ja, gut, super.
Und leiden Sie an Erkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater hat mit Blutdruck zu kämpfen
und die Blutfette sind wohl erhöht.
Und meine Mutter, die hatten Diabetes,
und der Arzt hat ja wohl gesagt, dass sie auch Gallensteine hat.
Mutter, Diabetes, und?
Ja, Gallensteine.
Gallensteine.
Okay, Diabetes, wissen Sie, welche Top?
Eins oder zwei?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Was ist zwei verschiedene Topen Diabetes?
Das ist Beziehung Insulin.
Also, Sie bekommt Insulin, ich weiß aber nicht, ob das zwei oder eins ist.
Das kann ich nicht sagen, ich bin leier.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das ist der Unterschied eins.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Muller, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund, ja.
Ja, super.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Werkzeugmechaniker.
Welche Mechaniker?
Ja, so ein Industrieberuf, ich bin Metallberufler.
Metallberufler.
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit oder in der Familie?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Sie leben mit Ihrer Familie, oder?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Familie.
Okay, Herr Muller, ich habe die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie eine Frage an mich?
Oder mussten Sie etwas hinzufogen?
Nein, erst mal nicht.
Sie sollen mir nur helfen, dafür finde ich da.
Sagen Sie mir einfach, was ich habe und was man dagegen tun kann?
Ja, natürlich, wir sind da, Ihnen zu helfen.
Aber es ist ein bisschen früher.
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Vielleicht haben Sie eine hohles Zestitis.
Das ist eine hohles Bladderentzündung.
Aber natürlich, bevor wir das bestätigen,
müssen wir ein paar Unterrichtungen machen.
Ein paar Unterrichtungen, Blutabnahme und operative Untersuchungen.
Und dann wir noch einmal.
Wie lange wird es dauern?
Mindestens eine Stunde.
Das hängt von unseren Kollegen in der Radiologie.
Und die Labor auch in Untersuchungen.
Mindestens eine Stunde bis zwei Stunden.
Entschuldigung, was ist Radiologie?
Das ist Rondchenabteilung.
Sie brauchen Ultraschalldurchfuhren.
Abdomen Ultraschall.
Das dauert ungefähr 15 Minuten.
Aber natürlich, wenn es keine Patienten gibt,
die auch warten.
Alles klar, dann machen wir das.
Dann nehmen Sie die Plastik, ich komme gleich.
Alles klar.
Haben Kollegen und Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Haben ich etwas zu fragen?
Bitte nochmal.
Haben ich etwas vergessen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich frage die Kollegen.
Sie sind nicht beruflich, dass ich das mehr stechend bezeichne?
Kolikartik und Zehent?
Nicht Kolikartik, Zehent.
Hast du sie aufstößt oder Zotbrennen?
Zotbrennen habe ich auch nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind meistens mit dem Essen anfangen und zwei, drei Stunden.
Sind die Schmerzen abhängig davon, ob sie sitzen stehen, legen,
oder bewegungsabhängig sind?
Nein, die sind nicht bewegungsabhängig und auch nicht lageabhängig.
Ich habe gesagt, dass Ihre Sütulferenderung,
oder Wasalasferenderung,
die Schmerz und die Stuhlkonsistenz haben ich nicht gesehen.
Noch andere Fragen?
Können wir anfangen, Arstotzkischeebreh, Mohammed?
Nur eine Minute, bitte. Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Abend.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit vor mir?
Ja, klar, gerne.
Danke.
Sein Name ist Peter Muller, 48 Jahre alt und zahlgeboren am 6. August 1974.
Er ist 1,87 m groß und wiegt 19 kg.
Er hat sich heute seit zwei, drei Wochen bei uns wegen bestehender Schmerzen verstellte.
Der Patient bewischte, dass die Schmerzen postprandell seien,
die eine, die halbe Stunde nach Essen beginnen wurden.
Ja, anfangen oder beginnen, ja.
Und nach zwei, drei Stunden wieder weg wurden.
Abklingen, sagt man.
Ja, und der Patient klagte, dass die Schmerzintensität 6, 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala entsprechen.
Die Frage nach Obelkeit und Erspression wurde für Neid.
Auch so wie die Frage nach Fieber.
Ja, der Patient gab an, dass auch Fiebergefühl und Schuttenbrust gehabt haben.
Ja, er sagte, dass diese Beschwerden insbesondere nach Füttelessen.
Ja, die Frage nach Wasserlassung und Stuhlgang Veränderung wurden verneint.
Auch die Frage nach Erkrankungen und Obes wurden verneint.
Herr Muller, ja.
Ja, ja, die sind weiter.
Ja, okay. Herr Muller habe keine Allergien.
Er hat Kaffee und Verzweglichkeit.
Die Impfstätige ist vollständig.
Er ist viermal gegen COVID-19 geimpft.
Er hat keine langen Reise in der letzten Zeit.
Herr Muller, nehm ich keine regelmäßigen Medikamente,
bis auf Beiber der Überprofe, vor die letzten Beschwerden.
Er hat überprofen 400 Milligramm eingenommen.
Herr Muller, er braucht nicht.
Er drinkt Alkohol sehr selten, nur bei Feiertagen.
Nicht Feiertage, sondern bei Feiern.
Feieranlässen, sagt man.
Besondere Anlässen.
Bei irgendwelchen Feiern oder bei besonderen Anlässen.
Keine Feiertage.
Bei Feiern oder Besonderen?
Anlässen.
Anlass und Mehrzahl sind Anlässe.
Drückenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Annamnese ergab.
Eine arterielle Hypertunie bei Vater.
Und Hypercholesteriemi.
Bei Mutter ist bekannt Diabetes-Militus-Tub 1.
Und bei Il.
Bei Il wurde gefordert.
Bei Mutter.
Nein, nein, nein.
Gallensteine.
Gallensteine muss entfernt werden.
Nur Gallensteine.
Von Operationen hat keiner etwas gesprochen.
Die Mutter leidet an Gallensteine.
Ja, sie hat Gallensteine.
Ob das Gallensteine ist oder zu Stuhliteases, wissen wir nicht genau.
Nur Gallensteine.
Ja, okay.
Die Mutter leidet an Gallensteine.
Herr Muller ist verheiratet.
Das ist die Mutter.
Der ist der Berufler.
Von Beruf.
Er hat keine Stress.
Bei Arbeit oder bei der Familie.
Nicht bei der Familie.
Man sagt, bei der Arbeit oder in der Familie.
Bei der Arbeit.
Und in der Familie.
Ja.
Ja, ich kann sagen, auch er hat.
Vollorientiert, orientiert den Zustand.
Und er ist in guter Ernehmung zustand.
Ja, meine Verdacht Diagnose.
Auf diesen Anamnestischen Angeber.
Gehe ich von Kohle, holes Zestitis aus.
Und differenzial Diagnose.
Kohle, die Diases.
Hepatitis.
Dank, dass du das.
Und du lastest auf Kohle.
Ja, und eines dürfen sie im Oberbauch nie vergessen.
Corona.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also hinterwand den Fakt.
Ja, das darf man nie vergessen.
Wenn jemand Oberbauchsmärzler.
Ja, gut.
Was machen wir jetzt mit ihm?
Ja, für weitere Abklärung empfehle ich.
Kurvalische Untersuchung.
Inspektion.
Ja, ich gucke.
Die.
Augen.
Es ist klar.
Ja, sehr gut.
Hat er nicht.
Kein.
Das bedeutet, es gibt keine Steine in dem.
Kohle.
Aber das können sie so nicht sagen.
Sie können nur sagen, der hat keine Abflussstörung momentan.
Aber der kann trotzdem Steine haben.
Ja.
Total.
Ja, und auch.
Ja.
Und auch.
Wir.
Versuche oder.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, kann sein. Ja.
Ja.
um Organe Megeli zu gucken.
Herr Peter Megeli oder Herr Steno-Megeli?
Ja, ja.
Okay, aber Sie haben ihn untersucht und die Leber scheint nicht vergrößert zu sein.
Und Sie haben jetzt auch nichts Besonderes getastet.
Außer, dass wenn Sie den Oberbau reindrücken, das ist ihm schon weh tut.
Ja, Marffis Symptom, ja.
Das ist das sogenannte Marffis Symptom?
Ja, kann man sagen, muss aber nicht unbedingt sein.
Sie haben es jetzt gemacht, Sie haben ihn klinisch untersucht
und Sie merken, dass tut ihm da im Oberbau schon weh, wenn Sie da reindrücken.
Was machen Sie denn als nächstes?
Ich meine, Sie haben ihn jetzt untersucht und als nächstes käme dann was?
Wir blutabnahmen.
Sehr gut.
Entschuldung der Parameter.
Aha.
Ja, sehr reactive Protein.
Ja.
Blut, Blut-Sedimentation, Geschwindigkeit.
Luftkontrolle, Schutose.
Ja.
Und kleines Blutbild, allgemeine Blutbild.
Warum kleines Blutbild?
Warum?
Das ist die Routine, die wir wahrscheinlich brauchen, Operation.
Auch, ob Hemoglobin-Anemien gibt es oder nicht.
Okay, okay.
Ja, man kann auch ein größeres machen.
Ein großes Blutbild bedeutet ja nur, dass wir ein Differenzialblutbild machen,
um zu sehen, wovoraus die Leukozytten bestehen, wenn die erhöht sind.
Aha, ja, gut.
Ja, Bakterien.
Sie haben jetzt Labor abgenommen und Sie sehen, sein CRP ist erhöht.
Zereaktives Protein ist erhöht und der hat auch eine Leukozytose.
Also, Leukozytten so bei 15.000.
Ja.
Und das CRP ist bei 22, wenn man einen Normalwert so bis 0,5 hat.
Ja, das ist auch für die Städte,
wir haben einen Abdominal- und Ultraschall.
Ja.
Ja, das ist ein Blutbild, das ist ein Blutbild für die Leukozytose.
Ja, ob es gibt Colestitis oder Colestitis mit Coletiasis.
Ja.
Und Coledocos, wie sagen wir, Coledocos?
Ja, Coledocos, Coletiasis.
Ja, und auch für die andere Organe.
Ja, Coletiasis, wie Lieber und Pankreis.
Ja.
Ja, Coletiasis, zu ausschließen.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Also, Sie haben ja Blut abgenommen.
Und ob der eine Pankreiasis hat oder nicht,
können Sie ja ganz einfach an den Blutwerten meistens erkennen.
Der hat eine normale Amylase und eine Lipase, die normal ist.
Und dann können Sie ja, die Lipase sind normal.
Also Sie können dann von vornherein sagen, der hat keine Pankreatitis.
Ja, bei Laburviertel.
Ja, und was Sie aber sehen, ist, dass so die GOT und die Gamma-GT
so ein bisschen erhöht sind, aber nicht sehr viel,
sondern ein bisschen erhöht sind.
Ja, vielleicht, das ist als Lieberreaktion wegen...
Sehr gut.
Aber jetzt haben wir im Labor gesehen, der Mann oder dieser Mensch hat eine Infektion irgendwo.
Mehr können wir erst mal nicht sagen.
Und klinisch haben Sie einen Schmerz im Oberbauch.
So, jetzt müssen Sie aber weitermachen.
Jetzt müssen Sie gucken, um ganz sicher zu gehen, wo der Fokus ist,
machen Sie, wie Sie gesagt haben, ein Ultraschalt vom Bauch.
Das wäre der nächste Schritt.
Ja.
Und wenn jemand eine Colizistitis hat, was sehen Sie denn da?
Was sehen Sie denn im Ultraschall?
Es gibt Odem in dem Galblada Wand.
Ja, Galblasen Wand, sagt man im Deutschen.
Galblasen Wand, Odem.
Auch...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch Deutsch, aber...
Hippoicoische Wand.
Echoarme Wand.
Echoarme.
Echoarme, Schweizer.
Echoarme ist Schaar.
Auch für Größte Galblasen.
Ja, für Größte Galblasen.
Sehr gut.
Und eventuell Erweitepläse gänge.
Ja, das kann sein, wenn da eine Abflussstörung da ist.
Ja, sehr gut.
Aber im Deutschen ist es ein ganz bestimmtes...
Ja?
Ja, sagen Sie, was Sie sagen wollen?
Ich möchte sagen auch Odem in dem Fettgewebe,
rund die Galbläse.
Ja, das kann auch sein, richtig.
Aber was ist egal?
Minimale Freie Früßigkeit.
Freie Früßigkeit.
Um die Galblase herum, manchmal ganz diskret, ja?
Ja.
Aber für die Galblase gibt es im Deutschen einen Begriff.
Da sagt man eine Dreischichtung der Galblasen Wand.
Dreischichtung, ja.
Dreischichtigkeit.
Ja, Dreischichtigkeit.
Oder das, das die Galblasen Wand, wenn man die anguckt,
dann sieht man so drei Schichten.
Das ist das Gleiche, was Sie eben gesagt haben.
Also Ideenbildung und die eigentliche Wand.
Und dann eben die äußere Schicht.
Aber die kommt sehr, sehr stark im Echo dann zum Tragen.
Als Zeichen einer akuten Entzündung.
Ja.
Und wie Sie es gesagt haben, diese freie Flüssigkeit im Galblasen
ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Bett, um die Galblase herum.
Und manchmal auch so ein Ideen, um die Galblase als Reaktion.
Ja.
Gut.
Jetzt noch eine letzte Frage.
Im, in anderen Ländern machen vielleicht Radiologen den Ultraschall.
Aber hier in Deutschland macht das der Gastroenterologe oder
der Internist.
Ja.
Nicht, nicht zum Radiologen schicken.
Die Radiologen sind hier nicht die Spezialisten für Ultraschall.
Sowas dürfen Sie in der Prüfung nicht sagen.
Sie rufen entweder den Gastroenterologen
konsiliarisch dazu.
Oder aber wenn Sie selber Internist sind,
versuchen Sie selber mit dem Ultraschall drauf zu gucken.
Aber nicht zum Radiologen schicken.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Und noch eine Korrektur.
Ob die Mutter von dem Patientin einen Typ 1 Diabetes hatte,
wissen wir nicht.
Insulin bedeutet nicht immer Typ 1 Diabetes.
Man sagt mittlerweile Insulinpflichtiger Diabetes,
ob Typ 1, Typ 2 oder Typ 3, wissen wir momentan nicht.
Das muss man genau erfragen.
Sonst macht man einen großen Fehler.
Da müssen Sie aufpassen.
Wir sagen Insulin.
Insulinpflichtiger Diabetes.
Insulinpflichtiger Diabetes, Meletus.
Gut.
Und jetzt haben Sie gesehen, der Mann hat eine akute
Polycystitis.
Was machen wir jetzt mit dem?
Sollte sich meine Verdacht der Akute Polycystitis bestätigen,
schlage ich folgende therapeutische Maßnahmen.
Stationäre Behandlung.
Essen, Karrens.
Und Entroffene Flüssigkeit.
Ja, sehr gut.
Antibiotika,
Annihiatika, Naturliasch.
Ja, sehr gut.
Was klingt das Antibiotika?
Wir haben eine Kombination von Aerobik
Und Aerobik und Aerobik, ich weiß nicht, auch deutsch, Aerobische und Aerobische.
Ja, richtig, aber welche Medikamente sind das, was Sie da so geben?
Ja.
Sollte auch schon Namen nennen.
Ja, mit Render Sohn, ja, geben, mit Render Sohn und...
Ja, sehr gut.
Und Zyphalosporin, auch, vor positiven Medikaten.
Bakterien.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Also die Kombination ist schon korrekt.
Sie sollten sich allerdings noch mal genauer angucken, welche Zyphalosporinemann da gibt.
Man gibt da meistens immer die Drittgenerations-Zyphalosporine.
Man kann aber auch Kipptatz geben mittlerweile, damit man sehr breit das Ganze...
Zyproflexation kann man eventuell als Alternative für Metronidazol geben.
Aber wie gesagt, üblicherweise gibt man Metronidazol kombiniert mit Drittgenerations-Zyphalosporin
oder Piparazilientazobaktamen.
Das ist das, was man so wissen muss.
Und was macht man mit dem dann sonst?
Und was wir noch vergessen haben, im Ultraschall haben sie nicht nur eine auffällige Gallenblase gesehen,
sie haben auch gesehen, in der Gallenblase sind auch Konkremente.
Ja, nach dem akuten Wase, wie operative Behandlung-Vorschläge.
Ja, sehr gut. Aber entscheiden Sie, ob die Operation erfolgt oder nicht?
Noch einmal bitte, ich habe Ihnen feststellen lassen die Frage.
Wer entscheidet, ob eine Operation gemacht wird oder nicht?
Herr Kollege, Sie müssen den Chirurgen dazu rufen.
Wenn Sie eine akute Kollektivität...
Sie müssen ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern,
weil der muss nämlich die Indikation für eine Operation sehen
und der wird Ihnen dann sagen, wie es weitergeht.
Aber gewöhnlich sagen die, eine akute Gallenblase wird nicht operiert.
Erst muss die Entzündung abklingen und dann holen Sie aber die Gallenblase raus,
weil solange der Mann diese Steine drin hat, die als Ursache für die Gallenblasenentzündung wahrscheinlich sind,
muss die Gallen entfernt werden.
Das musste ich chirurg sagen.
Und dann sagen die dann auch, wann das Ganze erfolgen soll.
Was weiß ich, drei Wochen später oder vier Wochen später.
Das haben Sie super gemacht.
Schönen Abend.
Alles klar.